did you know model Garden provides a
curated collection of over 100 models
including Enterprise ready Foundation
model apis open-source models and task
specific models from Google and third
parties it's a single place to search
discover and interact with a variety of
Open Source models like llama 2 stable
diffusion for image generation Bert and
Falcon instruct and first party models
like Palm for chat and for text imagine
for text to image generation and editing
Cod for code completion and Chirp for
speech to text users can kick off a
variety of workflows including using the
model directly as an API tuning the
model in generative AI Studio or
deploying the model directly to a data
science notebook in vertex Ai and you
can easily customize these models with
your own data deploy to Applications
with just one click and of course scale
with endtoend mlops buil in